we are watching some of the stories we
think you'll be talking about today
including this beginning with some sad
news we're remembering Grant Imahara a
former co-host of the hit science show
MythBusters on the Discovery Channel
aren't you guys the moment of truth for
our prison escape ropes we got a hundred
percent human hair toilet paper wrote
and the old school classic bedsheet well
the electrical engineer worked on
Mythbusters for nine years before moving
on to co-host White Rabbit project on
Netflix see mojado died yesterday
reportedly after a brain aneurysm he was
just 49 years old and Tony
he wasn't just known in my geek circles
for his roles on TV Imahara also worked
behind the scenes on the Matrix sequels
movies like AI Terminator 3 Jurassic
Park he also operated r2d2 in the Star
Wars prequels and even starred as
lieutenant Hikaru Sulu in a Star Trek
web series yeah it's a big loss you know
he said growing up he never wanted to be
James Bond he wanted to be Q the guy who
gets to make all the gadgets one of his
co-hosts said the gadget he wants to
make right now would be a time machine
because it doesn't want to live in a
moment without him